ميسي الى اين او باسلوب مونديال قطر ماسي
بس ما كسروا عينه
سؤال طبعا يطرحه كل محبي كره القدم
الباحثون خلف مستقبل البرغوث الارجنتيني
ميسي مع اقتراب نهايه عقده من باريس سان
جيرمان هذا النادي اللي يلعب له وهذا
المستقبل الذي تحاصره التكهنات هذه الايام
يبدو انه سيشهد لحظات ساخنه في الصيف
المقبل مع تضارب الانباء عن وجهه النجم
الارجنتيني الحنين الى كتالونيا هو
العنوان العريض لصحف اسبانيا لا سيما تلك
التي تخرج من برشلونه والحديث بالطبع عن
عوده ميمونه لمعشوق البرشلونين الاول الى
بيته ولكن وسط كل هذا تظهر رايات نادي
الهلال السعودي الذي تكثر الاحاديث عن
اقترابه من ضم لاينال ميسي لصفوفه في صفقه
قياسيه وتاريخيه دون ان يؤكد احد ذلك حتى
الان ميسيلون ازرق
بس وانا
[موسيقى]
طيب خلونا نلخص سريعا ميسي وينه قبل اشهر
من الان بدات طبعا الاحاديث بشكل كبير حول
مستقبل النجم الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
خصوصا مع فتره في نادي باريس سان جيرمان
لم تكن بالمثاليه والمتوقعه هنا كانت
بدايه التكهنات بالرحيل بالفعل راينا
الخرج مع فريقه الباريسي من دوري ابطال
اوروبا ولحقته صافرات استهجان الجمهور
الذي حال ما يوما بان يكون ميسي لاعبا في
صفوف فريقه ليصبح الرحيل مساله وقت فحسب
رحله ميسي كانت الى الرياض قبل نحو
اسبوعين هي الشعره التي قسمتها ظهر البعير
في علاقه مع النادي الفرنسي الذي قرر
معاقبه ميسي لاعب بحجه انه لم يخبر فريقه
بانه رايح الى
بالفعل فمنع منع من حضور مباريات فريقه
والمشاركه بها لمده اسبوعين فضلا عن خروجه
ايضا باعتذار مصور عقوبه ميسي فتحت
الاحاديث وباب الاحاديث حول اقتراب
النهايه لقصه باريس
وميسي الارجنتيني يتوج بجائزه لوريوس
الرياضيه كافضل رياضي لعام 2023 وهناك
يقابل نجم برشلونه الحالي ليفاندوفسكي
لحتى تقولي الاحاديث التي نقلت او نقلت
بينهما انهما تحدث عن عوده محتمله
للارجنتيني الى برشلونه هذا طبعا هذا ربما
لا يحدث اكيد على طاوله ميسي وفقا تسريبات
صحفيه عقد تاريخي عنوانه العريض بالازرق
الهلال السعودي كل ما علينا ان
نحف على هو ان ننتظر لنعرف نهايه القصه
قريبا
ولكن كنا صاير رايح للزعيم
على كل حال سالنا الناس مشاهدينا في
السعوديه عن رايهم في احتماليه انتقال
ميسي الى نادي الهلال السعودي خلونا نشوف
شو قالوا
شيء طيب يعني بالنسبه للانديه السعوديه
وحنا نرى ان شاء الله انه في تقدم افضل
والله هذا خبر بيكون مفرح جدا وخاصه اذا
كان في نادي الهلال
بيكون بالعكس بيكون شيء طيب للهلال وطيب
لمسي في نفس الوقت انه يكون يشارك في احد
او انجح الانديه السعوديه اللي هو نادي
الهلال يضيفون نقله نوعيه لان تشوف مثلا
الحين مثلا المباريات من قبره يتابعونك
مليون الان مثلا دخل رونالدو يتابعون سبعه
مليون مو فقط على المستوى العربي وميسي
كذلك نفس الشيء مره كويسه
من لاعب عاد هذه ما شاء الله تبارك الله
عندنا كريستيانو يجينا ميسي من قدنا قول
لي بالله مين قدنا هذا شيء جميل جدا
بالعكس الاضافه للكره السعوديه والدوري
تبعنا يكون من اكبر
الدوريات اللي موجوده على مستوى العالم
حيصبح هاي صلت الاضواء اكثر عن المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وهيكون في تنافس ما بين
الهلال وما بين النصر كريستيانو وميسي
الاثنين من قطبين من اقطاب كره القدم على
مستوى العالم
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو هنا الصحفي
الرياضيه محمد حامد محمد صباح الخير صباح
الخير يا عادل الاخيره مع بعض وصباح الخير
يا راويه صباح الخير لكل مشاهدي قناه
العربيه
والله العقد في جيبك تبع ميسي وانت لك
عموله يعني أنا عندك العلم أنا من عشاق
مثل الامانه بس ما فيش والتقيت ميسي قبل
كده وسعيد بالنقطه دي في مسيره المهنيه
لكن ما يتعلق بعقد ميسي ومخليني اقول لك
انه من اكتر من مصدر وفي مصادر على احنا
كميديا او كصحافه عندنا قدرا ندقق قوه
المصدر او ضعفه صح
غالبا وبالنسبه كبيره هو الى السعوديه
والمفاوضات بدات من يناير ولما تفجر
الخلاف مع باريس سان جيرمان يعني اللي
نقدر نحسمه انه لن يستمر في باريس خلصنا
قولا واحده محسوم الوجهه القادمه غالبا
يكون الهلال
وخليني اقول لك ان ان المنفعه او الفائده
متبادله بين الطرفين السعوديه امام مشروع
كبير للسوفت باور قوه ناعمه ومشروعها
النهضوي يستحق ان يكون له جانب صفط ميسي
احد
وجوه هذه القوه الناعمه مع رونالدو مع
غيره مع القوه الرياضيه ومعروف ان الدول
الخليج طول عمرها عندها ذكاء في الاستثمار
الرياضي فكره انه رونالدو الان في
السعوديه مع نادي النصر هذا برايك راح
يكون شيء يشجع ميسي على الذهاب الى
السعوديه ام العكس ربما والله انا عايز
اقول لك على مفاجاه في كلام في الكواليس
برضو غير مؤكد ان احتمال ميسي يكون في
النصر كمان مع رونالدو
لا يعني تخيل لا احنا مش عايزين نتورط مع
الجمهور الهلال ولا جمهور الناس بس ده
كلام بيتردد بس طبعا مفيش لا احد يستطيع
ان يؤكد ذلك بالمناسبه من السنيوهات
المجنونه ان ميسي ورونالدو حينما انتزعت
عنهم مش انتزعت كفوا تتعامهم الاضواء انه
ينهي مسيرتهم مع بعض تخيل لو في نادي واحد
هيقضوا على كل الشباب حتى يعني هيستعينوا
شعبيتهم مره اخرى زي ما هو هو وجودهم بحد
ذاته في بلد واحد يعطي ذلك الزخم لما
كانوا في اسبانيا
ابتعادهم عن اسبانيا ربما كان هو الخفت
الاضواء
الاسباني نفسه خسر كتير جدا برحيل رونالدو
يعني افتقاد المنافسه بين الاثنين
اذا سمحتي
في هو السؤال
الصراع راح يكون عقد مين من الاعلى
رونالدو دي دي مع احترامي رونالدو عشاق
رونالدو المساله ما فيهاش خلاف راحت ميسي
ميسي خليني اقول لك بطل العالم يا جماعه
طبعا بطل كاس على غير فكره بطل كاس العالم
هو اقل عمرا كمان ثلاث سنين اعتقد عنده
مجال يعطي اكثر اكثر مماريا مهاريا هو
اعلى يعني ربما رونالدو لا بالعكس هي
المساله فيها المساله
لا انا مش ساوي شويه وبعترف بالحكايه بس
هي بس هي الفكره في ايه رونالدو عنده
زخم في حياته ميسي كره قدم فقط فهو ربنا
بيعوض خلينا نقول ميسي لاعب كره قدم
رونالدو لاعب كره قدم ولديه ستوري تحكى
خارج الملعب
زوجته
مؤثر بشكل على المستوى الشعبي والمستوى
الاجتماعي عنده حضور طاغي وعلى المستوى
الاعلامي كمان خلينا نقول طيب بلا شك انه
ما راح يكون فقط في كره القدم سيكونون
ابعاد اخرى في الساحه
السياحيه السعوديه كذلك مؤكد بصي يا عادل
راويه احنا احنا السعوديه وهذا الكلام ليس
من قبيل المجامله البلد المؤثر بتلاقيه
فارض نفسه في كل المجالات وعنده بعد عالمي
انا تخصصي رياضه ما اقدرش احكي في
السعوديه لها وجود سياسي وجود اقتصادي
وجود على المستوى الرياضي وزي ما قلت لك
الخليج طول عمره عنده قدره وذكاء بداتها
الامارات ودبي السعوديه ناجحه جدا حاليا
قطر الابهات العالم في المونديال وهكذا
فهو الخليل
لديكم سبت معين في الوصول العالميه بطريقه
سوفت خليني بس اقول رقم ونقول للناس كلها
صباح الخير اذا تم العقد وهو غالبا تم وتم
توقيع ميسي سيحصل على مليون يورو صباح كل
يوم
صباح العربيه ههه
اكيد اكيد
350 مليون اللي باقيين دول مش مشكله
نمشيها
350 مليون سنويا محمد هذا تصريح خطير
بالتوقع
فرنسيه اسبانيه وارجنتينيه
600 سنتين يعني احنا مش عايزين نبان بس ان
احنا بندق عليه هو بالتاكيد يستاهل ميسي
والهدف لميسي يستاهل دفع المال بالتاكيد
بنحكي عن 350 في السيزون
وبالتالي 600 في الموسمين لو حسبناه بحسبه
بسيطه تقريبا مليون كل يوم مليون كل يوم
الليله عادل على كل حال شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات